rising concerns this morning about the
fate of two american veterans who are
missing and feared captured by russian
forces in ukraine they are andy nguyen
and alexander drewke they left their
homes
in alabama to serve with ukraine's army
now this news comes as leaders of
several nato countries visit kiev in a
show of support for the ukrainian
president and the u.s pledges another
billion dollars in military equipment
for ukraine's army chris lipsey is in
harkev ukraine with the latest on those
two missing americans chris good morning
this is worrying news
good morning guys yeah so far the
families and the state department can't
confirm if the two men have been
captured here in the harkeev area but a
russian social media post appeared the
same day they went missing claiming two
americans were now their prisoners
near the russian border a fierce battle
soldiers say two americans volunteering
with a unit of foreign fighters in the
ukrainian army shoot and destroy a
russian vehicle
then in the fog of battle they go
missing their names are andy wynn a 27
year old who served in the marines and
alexander drookie a 39 year old iraq war
veteran drewkey's mother bunny spoke to
cbs mornings he felt very strongly that
putin needed to be stopped
because he said putin is not going to be
satisfied with just part of ukraine or
even all of ukraine before he went to
fight andy wynn was making wedding plans
with his fiancee joy black
he just had such a burden on his heart
to go and help these people
in need well i'm really hoping that we
can get some answers and find out where
andy and alex are and get them home
that's all i want is in the back
back safely
i just want to know where he is
now their whereabouts are unknown and
their future uncertain last week one
moroccan and two british pows appeared
in a russian-backed separatist court
where they were sentenced to death by
firing squad for fighting alongside
ukrainians as for these american
veterans their fate will depend on
diplomacy of the highest stakes at a
time when u.s russia relations are on a
razor's edge
as an american
i am so darn proud of him for being
willing to risk his safety
to
help democracy around the world
as of now the kremlin says it's unaware
of their capture the white house says if
confirmed it will do everything it can
to bring the two men home the question
is what will moscow ask in return guys
yeah we hope for the safe return chris
livesay in ukraine thank you